have you SE have you guys seen this yet
no dude this
is dude from the beginning crank the
volume on this first of all you ever
seen [__] eyes like
this anyone who knows me and my
long-term boyfriend know that we meet a
lot of our friends online these days we
have made a ton of friends in the Disney
he's
gay swingers by swingers swingers that
love Disney and I love to swing all over
Walt Disney World Resort the Grand
Floridian Main Street USA Cinderella's
castle Space Mountain and people love to
drink around the world well how about
swinging around the
world wait they might actually be has
Disney lovers from all over the world
and we all just come together in the
most magical place on Earth and heck why
not call it the most fun place on Earth
too we don't just trade pins at Magic
Kingdom we trade
Partners oh
boy dude I hate that
M today and maybe we'll see you there
have y'all gone to that website no let's
sign up right now I know has anybody
tried to see if the website he like
valid damn bro we just totally stepped
on her moment can we just let her do
that again that was like that was like
really important to her can I'm like
right get it over yeah can we run that
back just those last 5 seconds and we'll
show you a whole new
world oh damn yeah they're Advanced I
think they're Advanced I think they're
on to some [__] like dude that is so
funny because I was saying to Drew cuz
we have a friend who was like doing some
big
like you couldn't type that no big what
sorry he was just like he just said
swingers at Maine into his phone oh no
we're going to visit in the browser yeah
yeah don't
trip um damn that worked on you you're
like [__] literally I'm like
they're I'm like complimenting them I'm
like no they're Advanced like let me get
do you know if they're still open or
like do they have all their spots full
they both you were saying oh but we had
a friend who was doing some like crazy
roll out and we assumed they were going
to like come out as straight and me and
Drew were like that would be so funny if
they did that they didn't end up doing
that and then me and Drew were like oh
my God we need to start making Tik toks
because everybody already says that
we're dating and there's all like the
grinder jokes and like the cheating
jokes and we're like we should just make
a whole new profile where we really go
in on like what I cooked for my husband
today and just him being like M I'm so
good
like yeah that's a very thing to do W
yeah that's what like straight couple's
do and stuff so good that's that's what
my wife does when I cook for her she
like oh
wow oh wow she's so hype oh what domain
doesn't exist oh let's hit casual sex I
I was able to find it on the cell phone
meet upon main.com is the real oh meet
upon M yeah they changed it on damn
that's a nice uh double meaning there
meet upon M yeah oh meet up on that's
what I'm saying they might actually be
on to some [__] they could be no that is
[__] awesome wait did they make this
an actual site or does this site already
exist who you got to pay I have to pay
the [__] yeah that's illegal that's
literally illegal like what wait y'all
don't do that what y'all don't pay to
have sex or no
prostitution like 89 that's a [__]
federal crime dude 98 a month 89 8988
the a chanted Enchanted membership you
be amazed what $89 could get you do we
have Drew's credit card can we sign up
for this it's real it is a real website
we should sign up guys oh wow the teacup
picture is kind of crazy like get off of
there kids get in there I wonder if
Disney has a division dedicated to like
making sure these people don't just you
know force them the on the property just
squat up in the park wait do they have a
Scientology building in Disney they
should wait go back to that picture Drew
you're giving too much Direction yeah I
can hear you clicking it's so be looking
for seeing that's the Scientology
building yeah it kind of does look like
it
yeah damn man people are so
brave putting themselves out there like
that yeah as I was saying that I thought
about like how much content of me there
is so like I'm one to
talk yeah what's what's more bold to put
yourself out there trying to be funny or
just putting yourself out there being
like me and my wife will [__] you and
your
hon trying to be funny dude I I would
say like this is more like commendable
to me cuz I'm like you really about your
business like [__] is your hobby and
you're passionate and like like
literally get yours like I'm proud of
you I'm really surprised with the amount
of alleged women on here yeah yeah if
they're not fake accounts cuz I would
expect nothing but dudes on here being
like I would like to be part of your
lesbian couple
like you're Disney lesbian have you ever
thought of expanding your mind yeah have
you ever wanted a mail to perhaps join I
am sis hat but I am
open wait are there like descriptions of
them oh hell yeah like what's up looking
for theme park vacation buddies man
you're on the wrong app yeah [__]
Friendster
brother oh wow she's literally a silly
girlly girl like she's literally a silly
girl like she's like that girl with a
bag of chips on her head yeah like I'm
crazy we can't take her anywhere it's
good thing we know that about her yeah
yeah yeah what else can we know about
this wait she posted this 27 minutes ago
she just signed up oh she she just
signed up she's locked in and she's
verified wait you can get verified on
here I'm like wait now I got now I got
to
haveen any social media platform where I
could be verified I'm like wait what you
sign up immediately so they have blue
checks H yeah we got a damn look at no
we skipped right past that was that her
badgering Gaston yeah it was sexually
harassing a worker yeah yeah
weird dude this kind of stuff is just
insane like I I like Disney bounders or
like people who go to Disney a lot
really really [__] freak me out what
do you call them Disney what Disney
bounders is that what they're called
they're called uh I said that earlier
but I truthfully don't fully know what
it means man the way you use the English
language is so awesome thank you thank
you thank you you refuse certain words
and others are just very eccentric yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm a
I'm literally a monster you know that
those popup ride
blazes it is Disney bounding by the way
I looked it up what does it mean what is
the definition bound to Disney I don't
know to I just saw like when people love
to go to Disney bounding also just feels
like a BDSM ter okay wait Disney
bounding is a method of styling that
takes inspiration from a specific Disney
character cuz you're not allowed to
dress up like the characters because
then people would assume you work there
um no that's not cute that's really
weird oh my God let these people live
and have their fun there's not a lot of
things to be excited about in this world
and if they want to be excited about
dressing like Mini Mouse let them be
excited let them have cake let them have
cake get call a Victorian Prince one
time and just let them eat cake let them
eat cake these peasants no it's it's
weird bro sorry they have
measurements go to the
guy wait on dating apps is that normal
to put your height I don't know I think
it is normal to put your height cuz I
feel like straight like straight short
dudes hide that [__] cuz people are
always like he said he was 5'7 and he
came and he was 53 like that whole
[__] thing I've never had a dating
app in my life so that's I don't like
really yeah no I've never had that you
just refus I'm just lit like that like I
don't need that [__] like I have this
one Church app called grinder oh yeah
that she always getting she gets on to
me about all the time she's like he's on
it all the time I'm like talking to him
I look down and he's just on that app
well you know he's just meeting other
people with faith I know but like I am I
not enough faith for you no okay
absolutely not can we go to a GU he's a
straight man he hates his wife oh okay I
always forget that yeah duh
duh that's why I was always listening to
those podcasts you know dude yeah that
makes a lot of sense you are like a big
Joe Rogan guy love Joe Rogan Joe's your
man mhm I still don't know what that
person looks like we showed Ina five
people on a screen and one of them was
Joe Rogan and just five random other
white celebrities and she literally
could not guess if it was Joan I feel
like you you don't have a dating you've
never used a dating app and you don't
know what Joe Rogan looks like I'm
useless a girl's girl she's just in
1980 I'm stuck no I'm just mean like I
just mean like you're just living in a
different world like yeah I don't know
that
guy